PETER NORVIG: Welcome
everybody.
It's our pleasure to have
with us at Google
today, Daniel Dennett.
He has a long and distinguished
career.
I won't try to summarize
all of it.
You can Google it.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER NORVIG: Instead, I'll
just try to introduce very
briefly the book that he's
written most recently and is
talking about today, which
is a collection or a
tool kit for thinking.
And I think the reason I think
it's such a great book is
because a lot of it
is our tool kit.
It's these computational tools
for thinking that we take for
granted, but Dan is trying to
introduce to the rest of the
world who sometimes aren't
aware of how
to think like that.
And so what do I mean by that?
Well, in his 1995 book on
evolution, he wrote that,
"Life on Earth has been
generated over billions of
years by an algorithmic
process." And that's kind of a
natural way for us to think
about it, but it's hard way
for other people
to think about.
And some people don't quite
understand that by taking lots
and lots of small steps that you
could arrange and come up
with this result.
And other philosophers, who we
won't name, have taken the
approach, well look at these
incredible results.
And if I simulate the steps
for three or four steps I
don't get there.
So it must be magic.
Rather than saying, well, maybe
a billion or 100 billion
is actually qualitatively
different than a couple steps.
So Dan reminds us how
to think that way.
He also reminds us that there
can be emergent properties
that aren't implicit in any one
piece of an ensemble and
yet they come out in the end.
We're all familiar with that.
Our programs have emergent
properties
that we didn't expect.
And we bang our heads
trying to fix them.
So we're aware of it.
But the rest of the
world isn't.
So that's why they need
a book like this.
I just want to talk about
one more of the tools.
And this is the using lay
audience as a decoy.
So this is a trick if you have
a philosophy professor who's
not explaining all the details,
rather than ask them
to explain a few you say, oh,
well why did you give a
lecture to this introductory
class.
And then it will become more
clear because the professor
will have to work harder to get
it to that level rather
than trying to keep it at the
professor to professor level.
One of our Google employees Rob
Pike wrote a book where he
talked about a similar
approach.
Instead of calling it the lay
audience as decoy approach, he
called it the teddy
bear approach.
Which is, there was a
introductory class in computer
programming for which the
TAs were overstocked.
And there was always a long
waiting line of students
waiting to get in to talk with
the TAs about why the program
didn't work.
So what they instituted was a
chair that held a teddy bear
outside their office.
Before you were allowed to talk
to the TAs you had to
talk to the teddy bear.
And so the students would come
up and say, oh teddy bear, my
program doesn't work.
And it must work because this
loop, see, this could never be
more than one.
Oh, except, oh, never mind.
And it turns out the teddy bear
successfully solved about
half the problems.
And people didn't have
to go on to the TA.
So I think that's sort of
in the same toolbox.
And Dan will tell you about
the rest of the tools.
DANIEL DENNETT: Thanks, Peter.
That's a great introduction.
I'm going to add
the teddy bear.
It occurred to me as you were
telling us about that, that
that probably explains the
success rate of psychoanalysts
right there.
You can replace them with
a teddy bear and
get the same results.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DANIEL DENNETT: Yeah, Teddy
bears are a lot cheaper.
So I want to talk about better
tools for thinking.
One of my best students, a Swede
name Bo Dahlbom once
said, "You can't do much
carpentry with your bare
hands, and you can't do much
thinking with your bare
brain." He hits the nail on
the head right there.
It's obvious, in a way, when
you think of it, even
something as simple as
a word is a tool.
It's a thinking tool.
And these thinking tools have
been around for a long time.
And recently we've learned
that maybe these thinking
tools are having a remarkable
effect.
How many of you know what
the Flynn effect is?
Oh, a few of you do.
And the rest of you, all right,
now let me tell you
about the Flynn effect.
Jim Flynn, it's named after him,
but he's not really the
one that did the
first research.
He's the one who drew people's
attention to it.
It turns out that IQ
worldwide is up.
And it's up a significant
amount.
If you use today's test, if you
gave that test to a person
who got 100 back in the '30s
they get probably an 80.
And we'd be viewed as
almost retarded.
I mean, there's a big jump.
It's like 20 or 30 IQ points.
Of course, IQ tests are always
scaled with 100 as average.
But if you use the same test
items, at the very least we've
gotten a lot better at
taking IQ tests.
And it has nothing directly to
do with how much tutoring or
schooling or your genes.
It's a very large effect.
And it can't be due to
improvements in our genes as
we're talking about such
a short time periods.
Jim Flynn thinks-- and
I hope he's right.
That doesn't mean he's right,
but I think there's a lot to
be said for it-- that what's
happened is that the thinking
tools that are first developed
and tested and debugged by
scientists and engineers and
other professional thinkers
have been filtering down into
every day people's thinking.
Even as simple an idea
as percentage.
Which kids, you just pick
it up very fast.
And 50 years ago, 100 years
ago, that was a pretty
complicated concept for
a lot of people.
They just weren't
ready for that.
And so probably it's all these
thinking tools that we install
without even realizing
we're doing it.
We install in on our own brains
and in other brains.
Probably that is a main source
of our improved thinking.
And certainly that is the thesis
that I want to explore,
in any case.
Because what I'm doing in this
book, as a philosopher, I
discovered that a lot of my
colleagues are remarkably
unselfconscious about the
tools of the trade.
Weird because philosophers are
famously self conscious and
reflective and navel-gazing.
But a lot of them don't
ever ask wait a
minute, how do I do that.
And why do I think that's a
good way of proceeding?
What tools am I suing?
And I wanted them to become
more self conscious.
I want everybody to become more
self conscious about the
tools that they use.
So what kind of thinking
tools are there?
There's words, as I say.
And numbers, of course.
And diagrams and maps
and methods.
And intuition pumps.
Which is a term I coined
more than 30
years ago to describe--
well in the first instance it
was John Searle's notorious
Chinese room.
And since I was beating up on
that intuition pump, a lot of
people thought I thought that
intuition pumps were bad.
No, I think they're wonderful.
It's just got to
have good ones.
There's defective pumps.
And there's good ones.
And the way you tell the
difference is, as you know, by
reverse engineering.
Doug Hofstadter came up with the
lovely phrase, you want to
turn all the knobs on an
intuition pump to see what
makes it do its work.
You want to try out
the variation.
Nothing mysterious about
why that works.
Is just Mill's method
of differences.
You're just empirically testing
to see what variations
make what differences.
See how robust the intuition
pump is under deformation.
And sometimes they're remarkably
sensitive to tiny
variations in the way
you tell a story.
Then you know it's probably
a defective pump.
Not doing what you
think it's doing.
So what intuition pumps
are are persuaders.
And it's important that
they're persuaders.
So much good thinking is
accomplished in a friendly but
competitive environment where
I am trying to persuade an
interlocutor, a target, that P
and the target is trying to
persuade me that not P. And
this opponent process is
actually a good way,
very often, of
getting at the truth.
So they're also discoverers.
They're attention-holders.
And they're anchors for
a fixed points.
In my work in philosophy there
are no fixed points.
That's the point a philosophy.
Philosophy is what you're doing
when you're not quite
sure what the right questions
to ask are.
And everything is up for
reconsideration always.
But how do you proceed then?
You say, well, maybe this as
a fixed point for this
discussion.
And then you sort of put
a pin down here.
And here's one here.
And then you say,
well, suppose we
take those on board.
What can we do with this idea
with a few of these candidate
fixed points?
One thing you may do with them
is throw all three of them out
or throw out one against
the other two.
It's in this intellectually
informal.
There's no algorithms for doing
this, certainly not yet.
This is an informal exploratory
process for which
there are really no rules.
But intuition pumps are
persuaders to use in those
harrowing circumstances.
Here's one that isn't in the
book, but I've talked about it
a lot recently and I think it's
important to understand
the context.
The MacCready explosion.
This is Paul MacCready.
How many of you know
Paul MacCready?
Oh well good.
I can educate you about that.
You will know him, not by name,
as the inventor of the
"Gossamer Albatrosss."
A visionary engineer.
The greenest of green
engineers.
Wonderful guy.
Died a few years ago.
And in a Ted talk a few years
back he came up with the
following startling
observation.
Let's go back 10,000 years to
the dawn of agriculture.
At that point, human beings
all around the world we're
beginning to domesticate animals
and plants, of course.
And at that point, our species,
Homo sapiens, and
these are, of course, entirely
modern Homo sapiens.
At that point 10,000 years ago,
if you put them on one
side of the balance scale
together with their pets and
livestock, all the domesticated
vertebrates on
one side, including us.
And you put all the rest of the
terrestrial vertebrates on
the other side.
Animals, not the insects, not
the worms, not the fish.
He calculated that at that time,
10,000 years ago, we and
our livestock accounted for a
fraction of 1% by weight of
the terrestrial vertebrate
biomass.
What do you think the
percentage is today?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: 10%.
DANIEL DENNETT: 10%.
AUDIENCE: Over 50%.
DANIEL DENNETT: Over 50%.
AUDIENCE: 99%.
DANIEL DENNETT: 99%,
are you kidding?
No it's 98%.
It is 98%.
We human beings have engulfed
the planet.
This is one of the most
astonishing biological
phenomena that has
ever happened.
And here's what Paul
said about this.
"Over billions of years on a
unique sphere, chance has
painted a thin covering
of life--
complex, improbable, wonderful,
and fragile.
Suddenly we humans have grown in
population, technology, and
intelligence to a position of
terrible power: we now wield
the paintbrush."
I've highlighted the technology
and intelligence
because those are the
thinking tools.
The only difference between us
and our ancestors of 100,000
years ago is the
thinking tools.
We have the same genes.
We have pretty much the
same justice systems.
The same muscles.
The same brains.
The thinking tools have changed
us and made all of
this power possible.
It is the source of our power.
Which raises a sort of
chicken egg problem.
Did evolved tools
make us smarter?
Or did we evolve to become smart
enough to make tools?
And like all good chicken
and egg questions,
the answer is yes.
It's a coevolutionary,
bootstrapping process where
you have a little evolution
makes us smarter.
And then we can be smarter
about making tools.
We became can become self
conscious about
the tools we make.
Our ancestors weren't
self conscious.
They didn't invent words.
They didn't coin words.
They just found themselves
using words.
And it made them smarter.
Now we are very deliberate.
We have become intelligent
designers of tools.
But initially we weren't
intelligent
designers of tools.
We were simply the beneficiaries
of tools.
Well how did they
get there then?
Not by the genes.
They evolved, culturally.
My next book is going
to be on cultural
evolution and that story.
But I'm not going to say more
about it now because I'm going
to be looking today at recent
tools intelligently designed,
supposedly intelligent designed
thinking tools.
Everybody knows reductio ad
absurdum where this is the
sort of crowbar of
logical argument.
It's what you use.
You take your opponent,
your target's premise.
You take your target's
thesis on board,
for the sake of argument.
And then you use the crowbar.
You try to deduce a
contradiction from that.
And if you succeed you win.
And we use it all the time
very unselfconsciously.
Very few people, probably
you've used to sort of
disguise reductio three or four
times in the last day.
You've said something like well
if that's a bear then
bears have antlers.
That's a reductio.
You'll find yourself
making them.
Now why do I bother mentioning
that since it's a very
familiar tool?
Because I want to point out that
rhetorical questions, the
questions you're not
supposed to answer.
Many of them, not all of them,
but very many of them are, in
fact, disguised reductio
ad absurdum arguments.
They imply a reductio ad
absurdum argument that the
writer doesn't bother
presenting.
It's too obvious.
It would be embarrassing.
So you just get the rhetorical
question and nudge,
nudge you go on.
So what I want to do is to
create in you a little alarm.
Sort of like a Google alert.
So that whenever you see a
rhetorical question in an
argument, ding.
You think, ah rhetorical
question.
You look to see, maybe
I can just answer it.
Maybe there is a perfectly
unembarrassing answer.
I remember years ago seeing a
"Peanuts" cartoon and then the
next to last frame Charlie Brown
is saying, "Who's to say
what the difference is between
right and wrong." Lucy in the
last panel says, "I will." and
think about answering a
rhetorical question but
just answering it.
See if you can do that.
A similar thing is what I
call the surely alarm.
Whenever you see the
word surely a bell
should ring, ding.
Let me just give you one.
Oh, yes, you could make a
computer they could sort fruit
by its color, but surely
no computer, ding.
Surely no computer could ever
have a favorite color or
appreciate color
When you hear that surely
you are being--
now maybe you think, I go
along with that one.
That's got to be right.
Actually in this audience I
bet a lot of people say, I
don't think that's so obvious.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL DENNETT: Why surely?
Well the author wants to get
this proposition, the
proposition that follows
it into the discussion.
Thinks it's true.
Thinks it's obvious.
But it's not quite obvious
enough so that it
goes without saying.
If it did you wouldn't
have to say it.
It would go without saying.
It goes with saying, but he
doesn't bother arguing for it.
So he gives you just a little
nudge and says surely.
So be on the lookout.
I tested my hunch about
this by going
through, thanks to Google.
Thanks to string search.
Going through some dozens of
philosophy of mind papers that
were online.
Counting up the surelys.
Most papers don't have the
word surely in them.
But I found several dozen
instances of surely.
And about 1/3 of them were I
thought clearly cases of this
was the weakest place on
the whole argument.
This is the place you
want to look first.
So now if I've alerted
you on rhetorical
questions and on surely.
Another one is rathering,
rather.
As in, it's not the case
of blah blah blah.
Rather it's ta da da da.
Rathering signals a dichotomy.
And very often it singles a
false dichotomy and what you
should do is, again,
have a little
alarm ring for rathering.
When you see the word rather
take a good hard look and see
if you can't say, well
maybe both blah blah
blah and da da da.
That hasn't been asserted.
It's just been presupposed
and glossed over
with the word rather.
So if I get you to adopt these
habits, look what I've done.
I've installed an app
on your necktop.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL DENNETT: And I
mean that literally.
The thing between your ears
is a kind of computer.
And I don't have to tell you
folks, but the power of a
computer is the apps
and the levels.
And you can build and build and
build and build and build
apps on top of apps.
That's what the thinking
tools do.
And that's what makes
us smarter.
A CPU without an operating
system, you can't do
very much with it.
You start building up all the
software and that's where the
power comes from.
I don't have to tell you that
computers are thinking tools
par excellence.
And in the book I put
an interlude on
computers in the book.
And then Peter, I'm happy to
say, he mentioned that I want
everybody who reads the book to
come away with a little bit
more basic understanding
of just where
computers get their power.
One of the things I do, and
this is so eccentric.
I think that's probably the only
trade book in history to
have this feature.
In this chapter called, "The
Seven Secrets of Computer
Power revealed," I teach
everybody how to program a
register machine.
A Hao Wang simple register
machine that can just do
increment and decrement
and branch.
And they teach it how
to do arithmetic.
And then they teach it how
to do some other things.
And there's problem sets.
I've actually got some simple
problem sets in this book.
And I say, well you don't have
to do them, of course, but if
you really want to understand.
If you want to be a computer
for a while and understand
what it is.
And, of course, they
learn about loops.
They learn about counters.
They learn about all
kinds of things.
That they hear these words in
other contexts and they think
they know what they mean.
Now they're going to know
what they mean.
The reason I think that's so
important, and again, I know,
I'm preaching to the choir
here, is one of the most
important epistemological facts
about computers is that
if you can make a computer
simulation of
something that works.
You know to a moral certainty,
there's no magic.
There's no morphic resonance.
There's no psionic forces
or ectoplasm.
It's good old-fashioned,
every day,
hardened, honest causation.
And you just got a proof
of it because of
the computer itself.
That's what it is.
There's no place for any mystery
forces to play a role.
But people shouldn't just
take that on faith.
They should know in their
bones why that's true
and how it's true.
And that's what that section
is supposed to show them.
Some intuition pumps don't
even have words,
they're just images.
I love this one.
This is from my friend Matt
Ridley, wonderful evolutionary
biologist and journalist.
And it just startles
for a moment.
But what points can
you make with it?
I'll just make one
then move on.
On the left you see an
Acheulean hand-axe.
On the right, I don't have
to tell you what that is.
The Acheulean hand-axe was made
by our ancestors without
any discernible stylistic
change.
Without any discernible
design improvement for
over a million years.
Absolute stasis.
Amazing.
Some people have even thought
maybe it wasn't to be used axe
at all, maybe it was like
the peacock's tail.
Maybe it was, hey, you want to
see my hand-axe collection?
I am so good that I can make
hand-axes all day long and
still get enough to eat,
take care of myself.
Bragging.
Sort of like having
a Lamborghini or
something like that.
But notice at the one on the
right, familiar as is it is to
us, it probably has a rather
short lifetime ahead of it.
How many bet that there
will still be mice
in a hundred years?
Right, point made.
Now here's a similar
comparison.
On the left we have
a termite castle.
Australian termite castle.
And on the right we have Sagrada
Familia, the great
Gaudi church in Barcelona.
As I think you can see, they're
stunningly similar
structures.
And even internally, if you look
at the cutaways, there's
a lot of design features that
they have in common.
These are two remarkable
artifacts made by animals.
And yet, for all their
similarities, you can see at a
glance that they are the
products of profoundly
different histories of design
and construction.
The one on the left is, this is
bottom up Darwinian design
and construction.
The termite, the individual
termites, could
hardly be more clueless.
They don't know what
they're doing.
There's no boss termite.
There's no architect.
There's no blueprint.
There's no leadership roles.
There's no hierarchy.
This is bottom up activity.
And it produces that.
Whereas Gaudi, it's
almost comical.
He was like a cartoon
caricature of
the inspired genius.
Autocratic, dictatorial,
laying down the law.
He had blueprints
and manifestos.
He had accounts of everything.
And he bossed people around.
And he told the bosses how
to boss the people.
Classic case of hierarchical
design and construction.
Here is one way of looking at
the problem, I think, that
evolution and cultural evolution
has to explain.
How did our planet get from
the left to the right?
How did we get from termite type
R&D to Gaudi-type R&D?
I think the answer has to be,
well, Gaudi did not have a
bare brain.
He had all those
thinking tools.
And those thinking tools are
the key to opening up top
down, as it were, intelligent
design type design.
What Darwin showed us is we
don't need the intelligent
designer that lots of bottom up,
mindless grubbing around,
trial and error, will eventually
produce all the
wonders of the biosphere.
But then the process keeps
right on going
with cultural evolution.
And pretty soon it starts
to reverse itself.
And we get more and more
intelligent design.
To where we now have people like
touring, better example
than Gaudi, because he
really had the goods.
Who notice, when he built his
computer, he already had proof
of concept.
He had the blueprint.
He had the design.
He proved it all.
Nobody would have ever given
him the money to make that
computer if he hadn't proved
it in advance.
This is where the idea really
is leading the way.
That's intelligent design.
And we've got to explain how it
has happened to be one of
the fruits of evolution.
Because it wasn't the cause.
The Bible says in the beginning
was the Word.
No, no, the word, very
recent development.
The word is the beginning
of intelligent design.
The Bible is right about that.
Another thinking tool which is
just a picture, but what a
lovely picture.
And, by the way, this is Leonard
Eisenberg's version of
the Tree of Life.
And you can get it on t-shirts,
big shiny posters
that you put up in
your office.
There's all sorts of ways
you can get it if
you go to his website.
And what I love about it,
there's many different ways of
representing the tree of life.
This has a few nice features.
I just want to sort of point
them out to you.
I ran out of battery
at some point.
OK.
There's no other pointer
up here, is there?
I'll just do it like this.
Here's a pointer.
A thinking tool!
Right here on the end
of my finger.
How wonderful.
So time goes out radially.
Here's the birth of the earth.
Here's the birth of life,
the origin of life.
And as you can see, the bacteria
and the archea are
the first single-celled
organisms.
And then we have a period of
single-celled eukaryotes.
This is a great, great, great
moment in the history of life.
It's the eukaryotic
revolution.
When the endosymbiotic event
put two of these types
together they joined
forces and became a
more powerful thing.
This is technology transfer.
This is what happens when you
have two independent lineages.
They've been evolving
independently
for a billion years.
And now they join forces.
They don't all have to
reinvent the wheel.
They get the benefit of
each current, and
those eukaryotic cells.
All the rest of life
is eukaryotes.
You've heard of the Cambrion
explosion.
There it is.
In a very short period of time
tremendous flourishing of
different kinds of life.
A period of fantastic
fecund R&D.
How was it explained?
That's a story I'd love to tell,
but for another day.
You can see mass extinctions.
And then way over here, this
last little fork here, that's
about 7 million years
on that scale.
Which is about the length of
time since we shared an
ancestor with our nearest
relative, the chimpanzee.
And, of course, of that seven
million years, only a million
years at most has
any language.
Some people will push it
back a little further.
The Acheulean hand-axe comes
before language.
Some people think that's
a controversial issue.
But so now notice, Cambrion
explosion.
Fabulous.
The MacCready explosion
happens there.
And transforms the planet.
All thanks to thinking tools.
So now, a few recent intuition
pumps that are in the book.
Because I haven't really
talked about them.
These are these little
stories.
So here's an intuition pump I
recently devised to discomfort
neuroscientists and cognitive
scientists who have been going
around saying I think
ill-considered things about
what neuroscience teaches
us about free will.
So first a little
science fact.
Damiaan Denys, a very brilliant
researcher in
Amsterdam, has made a little
microchip which controls
obsessive-compulsive disorder.
You implant it in a
person's brain.
Really does a very good job.
Science fiction.
So one day this guy with OCD
goes to see his neurosurgeon.
And she implants one
of in these Denys
microchips in his brain.
Sews him up.
The anaesthesia wears off.
And as he's about to leave she
debriefs him a little bit.
She says, oh and by the way,
my staff will be monitoring
you 24 hours a day, seven
days a week from our
control room here.
And you're going to think
you have free will.
You're going to think you're
making your own decisions.
But, in fact, we're going
to be making all the
decisions for you.
Free will is just an
illusion for you.
Have a nice life, goodbye.
And he believes her.
Well, shiny lab, lab
coat, all the rest.
And as you might imagine he
becomes a little negligent in
his habits.
And a little bit aggressive.
And indulges in some of
his worst behaviors.
And soon enough he gets in
trouble with the law.
Gets hauled into court,
charged with a
fairly serious crime.
He says, but Your Honor.
I don't have free will.
How do know that?
Well my neurosurgeon told me,
free will is just an illusion.
It feels like I'm making these
decisions, but I'm not really.
So they call the neurosurgeon
to the stand
and ask her to testify.
And under oath she says, Yeah,
that's what I told him.
But it was just a joke.
I was just messing
with his head.
Now how many of you agree that
she did, not just a mean
thing, a socially irresponsible
thing.
But she did very serious
harm to this guy.
With her language, she did
nonsurgically she claimed to
do surgically.
She disabled him as
a moral agent.
By just convincing him that
he didn't have free will.
Now I ask my neuroscientist
friends, aren't you just doing
the same thing wholesale?
When you write these articles
saying, we have learned in
neuroscience that we don't
have free will.
The reason they say that turns
out to be very bad reasons.
Having to do with, well
everything in your brain is
determined by what happens
in your brain
a little bit before.
Yeah, of course.
So what?
That doesn't show you don't
have free will.
They have a very simplistic
idea of what free will is.
But it's the idea that would
actually ground moral
responsibility.
If you didn't have it you
wouldn't have moral
responsibility.
But they're not showing
that at all.
And I think that's
irresponsible.
Now you might say, well, if your
brain is determined, and
then you don't have free will.
How many of you are inclined
to think, if every event in
your brain is determined then
you don't have free will?
The general run of people think
that's sort of, even
obviously true.
So here's a little
intuition pump to
dissuade you from that.
Two lotteries.
In lottery A the winning ticket
is chosen after the
tickets are sold.
Most lotteries are like that.
In Lottery B the winning ticket
is chosen before the
tickets are sold.
And the stub is secretly put
in a safe for safekeeping
until the tickets are sold.
Now how many of you think that
you're a fool to buy a ticket
in Lottery B?
That only lottery A gives you
any chance of winning?
How many think that
they're even?
Yeah.
And so does most of the
rest of the world.
When you put in these terms.
They recognize that,
no, you've got a
chance either way.
And Publishers Clearing House
actually says, you may
already have won.
People see that they still have
a chance if the winning
tickets are chosen in advance.
But now think, if determinism is
true then all your lottery
tickets were chosen before
you were born.
At the Big Bang, if you like.
And sort of put in on a little
secret safe in your body.
And as life goes on, whenever
you need a coin flip, whenever
you need a little chaos, you
just take the next one out of
the envelope and you win
some you lose some.
That's just as free as if
there's a quantum miracle that
happens right then and there.
So what if they're
chosen first.
Well somebody might say, well
you see, if all your lottery
tickets are chosen before you're
born, you're determined
to have good luck on
some occasions
and bad luck on others.
You're determined.
Well that's true even if
indeterminism is true.
Even if indeterminism is true,
you're determined on some
occasions to win and some
occasions to lose, you just
don't know which.
Fairness isn't always winning.
You've got to accept the
fact that there's luck.
And that luck is consistent
with free will.
But a lot of philosophers
haven't seen it.
A very good one, David Wiggins,
once wrote some years
ago about what he called the
cosmic unfairness of
determinism.
And you can see, or many people
think, yeah right, it's
a bummer if determinism
is true.
But I want to ask what about
the cosmic unfairness of
indeterminism?
Just as bad.
You know.
Life isn't always a picnic.
That doesn't mean that we can't
be responsible agents.
Being a responsible agent,
having free will in the sense
that matters, has zip to do
with whether physics is
deterministic or
indeterministic.
Or whether your brain
is deterministic or
indeterministic.
Has to do with the software
you've got in your brain.
It has to do with the competence
that you have had
installed in your brain since
you were a little kid.
If you were trained with a good,
moral upbringing then
you make the right decisions
at the right
time most the time.
And you are, in general,
competent enough so when you
screw up, you are held
responsible.
Why?
Because you're good enough
to be responsible.
That's a long story.
I'm not going to say
more about that.
Time to quit this talk.
So the book is sort
of a tapas book.
There are 77 chapters.
And some of them are
just a page.
Some of them there are maybe
as much as 10 pages long.
And they each introduce a tool
making it autonomous.
I tried to make them all
portable and accessible.
So my recommendation
is to try them out.
Take them for a spin.
And above all, turn all the
knobs to see how they work.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL DENNETT: Questions?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So intelligent design
is better in some
domains than others.
We can design a very nice mobile
phone or computer.
When it comes to an economy,
well, some may argue, but so
far we've yet to show we can
intelligently design an economy.
Do you have, well
two questions.
First of all, what you think the
profit is of things which
are not very tractable to
intelligent design?
And do you think eventually all
problems we'll have the
right tools in order to
design everything?
DANIEL DENNETT: No, I think
there's a trade-off which
other people have described
pretty well.
Natural selection is
a great engine.
And it feeds on chaos and
so-called randomness.
But it works, remember,
by trial and error.
And there's an awful
lot of errors.
And it's a very wasteful
product.
Very wasteful way of
doing business.
You've got to have a
lot of failures.
And so that's what happens,
let's say, with an economy.
And to that extent, that grubby
old social Darwinist
line about how the survival of
the fittest in the economy has
some truth to it.
But that doesn't mean that we
should simply honor that and
make that a moral principle.
Because I think we have very
good reasons to think that an
unfettered, completely chaotic,
laissez-faire,
dog-eat-dog economy is
not a good way to go.
Too much harm can accrue.
You can get these winner
take all situations
which can be very bad.
You know about winner
take all algorithms.
You know about opponent
processes in the brain.
In the work that I've been
doing on how brains are
organized, I think, first of
all, they are computers.
But they're very, very different
from laptops.
Precisely because you've
got 100 million
or 200 million neurons.
Each one is like a
little termite.
They actually have their
own agendas.
There's no two alike.
And the way software works in
the brain is by creating
coalitions and getting them
to work together.
And unity is an achievement,
it's possible.
But it isn't built in
from the top down.
And once we think about the
brain being organized that
way, we should think that's
probably economies are best
built in that way too.
Without too much top down
central control, but with some
policing to protect us from the
excesses that otherwise
would accrue.
AUDIENCE: Could you give your
opinion on Newcomb's paradox?
DANIEL DENNETT: Yeah.
Do you know what Newcomb's
paradox is?
This is the one boxer
or two boxer.
OK, so you've got.
First I'm going to have
to explain it.
See if I can get it right.
So you're on a sort of quiz
show and you're given the
following weird choice.
You could be a one boxer, or
you can be a two boxer.
In one box there's a $1,000.
In the other there's $1
million versus $0.
It would be hard enough if you
had to choose either box A or
box B. Would you take a chance
on $1 million, or would you go
for the sure $1,000?
But that's not your choice.
Your choice is either to go
for a box of B which has
either got the $1 million
or nothing.
Or to go from boxes.
Got it?
Well one line of research, one
line of thinking, says well,
dummy, of course you
go for both boxes.
That way at least you get $1,000
and maybe get a $1
million and $1,000.
That dominates decision
tree, draw it out.
That's the one you should do.
And so it would be, except
for one thing.
The MC of the program tells you,
oh, by the way, you're
the 5,000th contestant
on the show.
And we're very good at
predicting whether you're
going to be a one boxer
or a two boxer.
And if we predict that you're
going to make the two boxer
choice, then there's only the
$1,000 in box A. We never put
the $1 million.
We only put the $1 million in
when we predict that you're
going to go for one box.
And do you want to know
our track record?
It's almost perfect.
They might add, well you know,
one poor devil went for box A
and it was empty, or box
B and it was empty.
And one lucky devil out of 500
or whatever, went for both and
got both rewards.
But in general it's a very
strong statistical
correlation.
So now I ask you.
How many of you go
for both boxes?
And how many of you go
for just the one box?
What's nice about Newcomb's
paradox is that it ain't
obvious at all.
And an awful lot of ink has
been spilled trying to get
clear about this.
And I have, myself, not spilled
any ink because I
still don't have a
firm view on it.
I tend to think there must be
something a little bit screwy
about the setting up of this
thought experiment.
But it's very hard
to show that.
And I highly recommend
it to you.
There's a lot of good things
have been written about it.
So I'm sorry I can't answer
the question.
I go back and forth.
Some days I'm a one boxer, some
days I'm a two boxer.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to ask you about
determinism versus free will.
Since you were talking
about earlier.
And, in particular, I think
Hofstadter would talk about a
lover's disparity there.
That determinism is kind of a
totally different question
then free will.
I wondered if you could
talk about that.
DANIEL DENNETT: Yeah Doug
and I have talked about
this over the years.
And Doug disagrees with me.
It's one of the few points where
he and I have a serious
disagreement.
And he's actually quite
pessimistic about this and
thinks that the sense of free
will that really matters is
one that we can't have because
of determinism.
And I've done my level best in
several books and many hours
to convince him otherwise
without success yet.
Unlike the fellow in my tale, it
doesn't lead him to behave
in a irresponsible way.
So there's at least to
could be said for it.
I think that Doug--
here's what I think
the problem is.
That the term free will.
Where does it come from?
It comes from every day.
It comes from the law
and from tradition.
It's not a scientific term.
It's a term you get from what's
called the manifest
image, in philosophy.
The world of colors
and dollars and
baseball and so forth.
Not the world of neurons and
proteins and atoms, or for
that matter, scientific laws.
When you look at it's home
territory, free will, you can
see it does two jobs.
And they both seem to be
definitive or constitutive.
On the one hand, it seems
definitive that well free will
means uncaused, it
means it's free.
There's no sufficient
causal antecedent.
For many people I think that's
just obvious that's what free
will means.
But the other thing it means is
it's the standard condition
for being morally competent.
For instance, how many of you
believe yourself qualified,
eligible, to buy a car
to take out a loan?
Yeah.
And you sign the paperwork
of your own free will.
Now there are people who don't
have that competence.
They're senile or they're
too young.
There's something you've got
that they don't have.
And it is your very condition of
your living a free life as
a citizen and conducting
business, making promises that
count and so forth.
I think that's the best
notion of free will.
That's the one that matters.
And I think that notion
has nothing to do with
determinism.
For instance, I don't think
your competence to sign a
contract would be disparaged
in the slightest if
determinism were true.
So I have argued for years
there's just no reason to
prefer that your brain
be deterministic over
indeterministic.
No reason at all.
No good reason.
I've recently had to back off
that a little bit by a very
persistent lover of
indeterminism and free will,
who finally showed me that there
was, by my own lights, a
condition where I would
agree with them.
I would wish for indeterminism
in that case.
And I'll tell you what it is.
You all know the game
rock-paper-scissors?
Well the best way to
play that game, of
course, is to play random.
It's very hard to fake
randomness or to put together
a random series.
If you're random you give you
give your opponent no pattern
to track at all.
So they can't do any better than
play random against you.
You'll break even.
So since that's the case, you
might just as well memorize a
few hundred entries in a table
of random numbers and use that
to guide your choices.
You'll do fine as long as
you don't let the other
guy see your list.
Which would be terrible.
So now I can tell you, here's
the condition under which I
would hope that indeterminism
is true.
If I were playing
rock-paper-scissors for high
stakes with God.
I don't really anticipate that
happening in the future, so I
am quite content to live out
my life in a deterministic
world and I'll take
responsibility for my acts,
even though they are, for all I
know or care, determined by
the kazillion things that
happened both before
and after my birth.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is consciousness an
epiphenomenon of advanced
biological systems and tends to
disappear as you look back
across the Tree of Life?
Or is it a fundamental dimension
to nature and
reality like the dimensions
of space and time?
DANIEL DENNETT: OK
you said or.
This is sort of a rathering.
You didn't say rather,
but there was a sort
of rathering there.
But I'll take it on because I
do not think that it is a
fundamental category that splits
the universe in two.
I think that the idea that it
is deeply rooted in culture.
And I suppose it
might be right.
But I think that consciousness
is like reproduction,
metabolism, and self repair,
healing, blood clotting.
It's a very interestingly
complex and deeply recursive
biological phenomenon.
It is not in the interesting
sense, and there's many senses
of consciousness.
In the sense that we in this
room are conscious, which is
the anchoring that's home base
from our own experience and
our reading of literature.
We read novels and
things like that.
We have the sense of what a
conscious life is like.
I think we're the only creatures
that have that kind
of conscious life.
I don't think dogs have it.
I don't think dolphins
have it.
They're sentient.
They're awake.
They feel pain.
But they don't have most of what
makes human consciousness
so important.
And I think that phenomena
is, in the end, software.
And I think it has
to be installed.
So it is an implication,
in my view, and
don't try this at home.
Don't test this.
That if a human baby could be
raised entirely without any
interaction with other
human beings and
cut off from language.
If it could grow to adulthood
without benefit of all the
thinking tools that would
normally be installed in the
course of just growing up
in a social community.
I think that human being would
have a mind so profoundly
different from ours that we
would all pretty well agree he
or she wasn't really
conscious.
Now that may be a very
eccentric notion of
consciousness.
But if you're wanting to know,
do I think that, if you look
for a better notion of
consciousness or one that
isn't so eccentric.
And you start thinking
about what it is.
The capacity to experience color
and flavor and to have
qualia, as philosophers say.
I think that's all pretty
badly confused.
And I've tried to say how
and why over the years.
But part of what makes it
confusing is it people want
consciousness to be, to
use a technical term,
supercalifragili
sticexpialidocious.
And if you're not talking
about something that is
supercalifragili
sticexpialidocious then you're
not talking about
consciousness.
And there's a quote my friend
Lee Siegel, he's a philsopher
and a magician.
A very fine stage magician.
Wrote a wonderful book on Indian
street magic called,
"Net of Magic."
And there's a passage in
there I love to quote.
He says, I tell my friends I'm
writing a book on magic and
they ask, do you mean
real magic?
And by real magic they
mean magical.
They mean thaumaturgical
acts and so forth.
And he says, no.
Not real magic.
Sleight of hand.
Stage magic.
And then he goes on, he says,
in other words, the kind of
magic you can actually
do is not real magic.
Real magic is a kind
that doesn't exist.
Well what I've come to realize,
my whole career, I've
been confronted with people.
Because what I want to deal with
are topics that a lot of
people think of as real magic.
Free will and consciousness
in particular.
And if you don't mean something
that as one
proponent of it says,
every free
decision is a little miracle.
If you don't think that that's
what free will is then you're
not talking about free will.
Not real free will.
You're talking about some
cheesy substitute.
And I'm all for this cheesy
substitutes, I'm afraid.
I think they're quite
good enough.
And science can explain why we
have varieties of free will
that are worth wanting, even if
they aren't real free will.
They'll secure our lives
as meaningful and
responsible and so forth.
And we can have consciousness
even if it isn't something
that sunders the universe
in twain in this
very special way.
Sorry it's such a long answer,
but you got me going.
AUDIENCE: What do
you think about
utilitarianism and moral reasoning?
DANIEL DENNETT: I'm not a
utilitarian, or at least not
an ordinary utilitarian.
I don't that any.
I'm a consequentialist.
That is to say, I think the
consequences matter.
I'm not one who takes
a strictly
deontological view of ethics.
Using some technical terms.
I want to try to get
away from them.
This is an issue that's very
close to the service in work
that I'm doing right now on
free will and punishment.
Because I say, no, we don't.
I notoriously said in my last
book on free will, I don't
want to live, no in an
article on free will.
I don't want to live in a world
without punishment.
And these people jumped all over
me and said oh, you dirty
retributivist, you.
I said, no, I'm not
a retributivist.
Kant was the great
retributivist.
And if you want to know what
bullet he bit, he said, if we
know the world was going to
end tomorrow, one of our
highest duties would be to go
into the prisons and execute
the people on death row.
By that he wanted he wanted us
to think that punishment was
in itself good.
That a crime unpunished
is a an offense to
nature or God or something.
And that's what a retributivist
is one who
thinks that punishment
is a good in itself.
I don't.
But I think it's a very
foundational good for a very
simple reason.
I want to live in a world in
which there are promises.
And you can't really have
promises unless there's
consequences for not keeping
your promise.
And those consequences are
not rehabilitation.
They're not reform.
They're punishment.
And it's OK.
And we should all be willing to
say, no, I'd rather take my
punishment.
I'd rather be a free citizen
in a free society.
I accept that if I do something
really wrong I am
eligible for punishment
and that's OK.
I think the world we live in,
when we have a system of law
and order with punishment, I
think our current system of
punishment is obscene and should
be completely reformed.
But I don't think we should
eliminate punishment as some
of the current crop of cognitive
scientists and
neuroscientists are saying.
I don't think they've look
closely at the last time this
was considered a really
wise move.
And that was back in the
Stalinist era when people
weren't punished, they
were treated.
I don't think we want
to be treated.
I think we want to
be punished.
Because then there's rules.
And you can serve your
time and get out and
be a citizen again.
An that dire note, I'll stop.
AUDIENCE: There was a decision
this week about patents that
touched on some deeply
philosophical issues.
The question was whether
software should be patentable.
And one of the opinions, which
unfortunately, didn't gather
majority support was that
basically things you do in
software are like
natural laws.
They're tools that everybody
can use.
And some particular arrangements
with these tools
should not be patentable.
Other judges felt that if you
have a computer and it's
programmed with software,
that's a new device.
And devices are clearly
patentable.
Do you have some wisdom
to offer us on that?
DANIEL DENNETT: Well I thought
about it in the past.
And I've thought about the
difference between patent and
copyright and trade secret.
And actually I'm trying to
think about this in quite
fundamental terms.
Because I think that what we
need to develop is the sense
of information, which is
distinct from Shannon-Weaver
information.
Which depends on Shannon-Weaver
information,
but is semantic information.
It's cognitive information.
And, to me, the best way of
thinking about this is that
it's useful information.
It is information defined as
that which permits the
transmission of adaptations for
one purpose, one utility
or another.
And then under that view then,
of course, software, I think
intuitively when we're measuring
whether software
what counts as theft, we have
to look at the utility.
And if it's the utility that's
been stolen, then we should
have penalties for that.
That should be discouraged.
The trouble is that copyright
law also involves this idea.
It's a good question.
And I'm not surprised
that the Justice--
Is this at the Supreme Court?
AUDIENCE: It's the Court of
Appeals for the Federal
Circuit that handles
patent cases.
DANIEL DENNETT: I want to
know more about it.
I'm not surprised that
they are divided.
I think it's a tough issue.
But obviously when I talk
about apps, as tools for
thinking, I am thinking of these
as mechanisms that have
been designed.
And so on that ground I would
tend to come down on the side
that you can patent it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]